le dîner de travail entre américains et
russes pour régler la crise en ukraine
vient de se terminer et les positions
restent antagonistes le vice ministre
russe des affaires étrangères
qualifie sa première discussion avec son
homologue américaine de sérieuses mais
compliqués
sont les américains qui doivent se
préparer à trouver un compromis la
partie russe est venu ici avec une
position claire nous ne pouvons tout
simplement pas changer notre approche
wendy sherman elle s'est exprimée via un
communiqué elle réaffirme le soutien de
washington aux principes de souveraineté
et d'intégrité territoriale
l'ukraine et les occidentaux accusent la
russie d'avoir massés près de cent mille
soldats en vue d'une potentielle
invasion du pays le but de ces
négociations américano russes qui se
poursuivent ce lundi à genève
c'est d'obtenir la levée de cette menace
militaire de moscou la russie exige la
signature d'un traité avec la garantie
que l'ukraine ne rejoigne jamais l'otan
mais aussi le départ des soldats
américains des pays baltes et de la
pologne le camp occidental de son côté
veut montrer à vladimir poutine qu'il ne
laissera pas un événement comparable à
l'annexion de la crimée par la russie se
reproduire
nous lui avons proposé deux options la
première à travers la diplomatie et le
dialogue la seconde sera une
confrontation avec des conséquences
lourdes pour la russie si elle
renouvelle ses agressions contre
l'ukraine la rencontre américano-russes
de ce l'on dit lance une semaine
diplomatique intense réunion otan russie
ce mercredi suivis jeudi cette fois
d'une rencontre entre moscou et les pays
européens de l'eau et c